[Music]
i have a picture of my head of a place
i don't know if it's real
but it has a feeling and the feeling's
real
hi my love hi dad i wanted to talk to
you about my graduation
i'm gonna be there in the bleachers i'm
gonna see you in your let me let me how
about i call you back
taking the day off in here your boss
wants to see you
i get a whiskey double you're real
sorry i want to show you something
really cool
you see all these people outside they're
not real
this is a simulation
you ready
there's my guy welcome home this place
is
overwhelming dr isabel clemens pioneered
brain box simulations ugly simulated
worlds to generate appreciation for the
real world
why am i not remembering any of this
don't worry about it
most people say ignorance is please
but i say you have to experience the
good
so appreciate that
you know the other way around exactly
i'm glad i caught you word on the street
there have been problems with isabella's
research
i'm a little disoriented you're my guy
graduation i did not forget it's been a
crazy few days
i graduated two weeks ago ignore her
she's not real
she feels real
i'm scared your head's not on straight
it's almost like a trick being played
great this is really bad
so how do we fix it
one of these days you're going to have
to choose
between these worlds
[Applause]
it's amazing how easy
humans can get used to even something
spectacular
[Music]
you